bienvenue à tous ravi de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro de Paris saclé TV
ce mois-ci nous verrons comment votre
territoire s'inscrit dans une démarche
environnement et transition énergétique
avec déjà ce collocque premier colloc
scientifique organisé ici même à EDF Lab
un collocque sur la transition
énergétique de jours de workshop
d'échange entre chercheurs entrepreneurs
et étudiants autre initiative autre
piste de réflexion le climaton alors cet
événement a eu lieu dans 121 villes à
travers le monde mais aussi à Paris
saacé nous étions présents et pour
lutter contre la pollution la pollution
des transports les plus courageux
d'entre vous les plus sportifs ont
choisi le vélo mais tout n'est pas perdu
pour tous ceux qui sont un petit peu
moins sportifs grâce à la start-up Clem
elle nous propose le véliible électrique
nous l'avons essayé enfin gros plan sur
un bâtiment qui prend en compte cette
dimension environnement transition
énergétique il doit accueillir les
étudiants de l'ENSAE ParisTech nous
allons vous le présenter et enfin notre
agenda tous les rendez-vous à ne surtout
pas manquer ce sera la fin de cette
émission bien
sûr nous voici donc à EDF Lab c'est ici
que s'est déroulé le premier colloque
scientifique sur la transition
énergétique de jours de réflexion de
débat entre chercheurs entrepreneurs et
étudiant sur ce thème devenu crucial au
cœur des débats cette question qu'est-ce
que l'université Paris sa-clé peut
apporter à la transition énergétique
tout de suite les précisions de
Françoise Toubou elle est conseillère
auprès de l'administrateur général du
CEA nous organisons aujourd'hui ici dans
les locaux de DF Lab à saclé le premier
colloque scientifique
sur la transition énergétique sur le
plateau de sacclet donc c'est organisé
conjointement par l'Université Paris
saccly et par EDF il y a ce qu'on
appelle un écosystème sur l'énergie qui
est vraiment vivant sur le le plateau de
Sacla on parle de la recherche la plus
fondamentale à la recherche appliquée et
aux écosystèmes industriels donc on a
décidé de faire un premier colocque
scientifique pour montrer qu'il y avait
de grandes actions de recherche qui étit
mené sur le plateau de de sacly et que
ces actions de recherche elles étaient
pas menées indépendamment par chacun des
organismes et que grâce à l'Université
Paris Saclay à cette commue nous avons
mis ensemble les chercheurs nous avons
créé des département de recherche ces
départements de recherche sont plutôt
disciplinaires mais ils ont chacun
l'énergie au cœur de leur préoccupation
l'énergie est un enjeu sociétal qui est
un un enjeu en particulièrement prégant
en ce moment puisque nous sommes 1 an
après la signature de la COP 21 et puis
un petit peu plus d'un an après la la
signature de la loi qu'on appelle la loi
ltecv donc la loi de la transition
énergétique pour une croissance verte
donc l'objectif de ces deux jour c'est
vraiment de montrer qu'est-ce que
l'université Paris saint-clai l'ensemble
de ses chercheurs mais aussi l'ensemble
de ses collaborations avec le site le
tissu industriel peut apporter à cette
thématique de la transition énergétique
en parallèle à ce colloque nous avons
organisé un forum étudiants qui permet
aux étudiants qui font leurs études sur
le plateau de saclclet de venir
rencontrer leurs futurs employeurs
c'est-à-dire soit des industries soit
des organismes de recherche et puis nous
donnons aussi une grande part aux
étudiants au sein même du collocque
puisque nous avons organisé une session
postère et nous sommes ici au milieu
d'une salle où vous voyez exposer les
les posters et à l'issue de ces deux
journées nous
attribuerons cinq prix aux meilleurs
posters qui auront été réalisés mais
c'est vraiment l'occasion aux doctorants
de venir présenter leurs travaux de
recherche aux 300 personnes qui sont
venues ici au colloque pour la
transition énergétique sur le plateau de
Sacy un territoire en pleine transition
énergétique et des défis à relever voilà
pourquoi Paris saclé a participé au
climaton un événement qui a réuni 121
ville à travers le monde autour de cette
question du climat à Paris sa clé le
rendez-vous été donné au proto 204 que
vous connaissez tous nous étions
présents alors que s'est-il passé de
quoi a-t-on parlit et bien
regardez le climaton Paris saclé 2016 en
fait c'est une initiative conjointe
entre plusieurs partenaires donc il y a
l'université Paris sain-clé il y a la
communauté d'agglomération Paris-
sain-clé l'établissement public
d'aménagement Paris sa-clé et la climate
kick c'est la première édition du
climaton à Paris sa-clé ça se déroule en
même temps dans 56 villes partout dans
le
monde tous ces acteurs en fait sont
intéressés pour travailler avec les
habitants avec différents différentes
compétences sur les problématiques de
développement durable de de gestion des
déchets de d'énergie tout ce qui est lié
en fait aux modifications climatiques et
l'objectif c'est de réunir plusieurs
participants avec différentes
compétences pour les faire travailler
sur des sujets vraiment liés au
territoire Paris sa clé sur la
transition énergétique pour faire
émerger des projets citoyens et pouvoir
les mettre en place à
postériori
les participants ils viennent d'horizon
divers il y a des étudiants il y a des
enseignants de l'université Paris saclé
mais aussi de de Paris il y a des
habitants aussi qui ont été invités donc
du territoire local et il y a des
entrepreneurs l'idée c'est vraiment de
mixer tout le monde pour faire émerger
une créativité plus
importante au finalc présenter son son
concept ou son son projet sur une
problématique qui aura été ciblée en
amont l'équipe qui va être vainqueur de
ce concours parce que c'est un challenge
donc il y aura un jury qui va élire
l'équipe qui aura rempli tous les
critères donc la viabilité du projet le
lien avec la thématique la motivation de
l'équipe elle pourra en fait faire des
entretiens avec les équipes de la
communauté d'agglomération pour mettre
en place en fait la solu qui aura été
imaginéquipe gagnante c'est organ po
voilà pour limiter la pollution des
transports certains d'entre vous ont
choisi il circule à vélo sur le plateau
de Paris saclé encore faut-il être
sportif ça monte et ça descend pas mal
heureusement Clem a pensé à tout cette
start-up nous propose le vélo électrique
nous avons essayé
nous sommes un opérateur français
d'écomobilité partagée nous avons
développé une plateforme qui permet de
gérer plusieurs services de mobilité à
savoir de l'autopartage de véhicule
électrique du covoiturage de la gestion
de points de charge et de l'information
voyageur donc notre offre de service
s'adresse à trois communautés euh les
collectivités les entreprises et puis
l'habitat
social le service de véloassistance
électrique est l'une des briques de
notre plateforme d'écomobilité que nous
essayons de déployer sur le plateau de
sa clé il vient en complément des
infrastructures de transport existante
et l'objectif c'est vraiment de
faciliter la liaison entre la vallée et
le plateau de saclé le service il
s'adresse autant aux aux habitants de la
ville d'Orsay qu'aux étudiants et
salariés qui arrivve sur les deux gares
et qui font quotidiennement le trajet
valet plateau de sa
clé le service est une expérimentation
de 4 mois elle s'inscrit dans le cadre
d'un projet européen on mettra en place
20 vélo assistance électrique à titre
expérimental sur cette station autour de
la commune
d'Orsay l'expérimentation de
véloassistance électrique autour de la
ville d'Orsay s'inscrit dans un projet
plus global qui va permettre de mettre
en place une flotte plus plus importante
avec 70 vélos électriques sur un
territoire plus important de la
communauté Paris saclé mais aussi un
service d'autopartage de voiture
électrique de réservation de points de
charge et aussi de covoiturage
l'ensemble étant géré sur une même
plateforme
d'écomobilité pour les gens qui sont
intéressés par le service ils
s'inscrivent sur le site internet
clin.mobi ou depuis l'application
clin.mob ils valident leur badge sur la
borne qui est installé Act ement à la
mairie
d'orsé l'utilisateur arrive au niveau du
vélo avec son badge il il badge sur la
boîte à
clé et là il y a le guichet de la boîte
qui va se
déverrouiller et on peut récupérer les
clés il y a une clé pour le vélo et la
clé pour le
cadem et enfin comme promis Paris TV
vous présente un tout nouveau bâtiment
qui prend en compte ses problématiques
environnement et transition énergétique
c'est un bâtiment de basse consommation
il est en construction il est juste
derrière moi il accueillera très bientôt
l'ENSAE paritetech un projet proposé par
l'agence d'architecture
cab nous abordons cette cette fin de
chantier comme vous voyez avec le
traitement des abords et notamment donc
ce ce bassin d'orage qui aussi était
très important dans ce projet parce que
hormis sa sa nécessité environnementale
aussi c'est une vraie scénographie
d'entrée depuis depuis le sud
parallèlement au nord donc on a un accès
principal des étudiants et des
chercheurs et et d'administration qui
arriveront un jour du futur métro aérien
ou pas aérien
d'ailleurs c'était un bâtiment qui a
nécessité beaucoup d'énergie beaucoup de
mise au point une très grosse synthèse
en effet vous le voyez c'est un bâtiment
totalement métallique he qui repose sur
un un un socle un socle enterré en en en
béton dans lequel se trouvent les
parkings et donc cette exostructure
était très intéressante là d'un point de
vue environnemental puisque c'est ce
qu'on appelle la filière sèche hein donc
l'ensemble du bâtiment c'est construit
comme un mécano au fur et à mesure donc
c'était extrêmement intéressant même au
niveau de la de la fabrication et de la
mise en œuvre de voir cet exo squelette
aracnéen comme ça se monter et ensuite
venir avec des systèmes de plancher qui
étaient aussi préparés sur place comme
ça posés au fur et à
mesure aussi ce qu'on a essayé de donc
de mettre en œuvre et à profit de notre
notre expérience cétait aussi d'aller
jusqu'au bout de cette démarche
environnementale à l'intérieur en terme
de secondde œuvre nous avons expérimenté
un un produit très intéressant qui est à
base de de de GIPS et qui donc pour le
cloisonnement euh va rester totalement
brut donc absolument pas ni enduit et ce
sont simplement des plaques qui sont
vissées et donc qui reprennent aussi
tout ce système si vous voulez de de
construction et et de aussi de
démontabilité possible à travers ce
matériau donc qui est comme des lambriie
euh qui suit parfaitement le module du
bâtiment évidemment on a cherché à que
ça soit le mieux dessiné possible et
puis que ça aille dans une idée d'un
bâtiment léger abstrait et effectivement
on se voyait pas sur ce plateau venir
avec un bâtiment en béton mais on
voulait plutôt rester dans dans une idée
de transparence de légèreté et rentrer
en écho et en résonnance avec le
paysage avant de nous quitter un petit
coup d'œil sur notre agenda le SIMI
c'est le grand rendez-vous de
l'immobilier d'entreprise et bien cette
manifestation se déroulera du 30
novembre au 2 décembre toujours au
Palais des Congrès à à Paris voilà c'est
la fin de ce numéro merci à vous de
l'avoir suivi c'était un Paris saclé TV
100 % développement durable et
transition énergétique tout comme votre
territoire on se retrouve très vite sur
TVfil 78 et pour plus d'informations une
seule adresse
epaps.fr I